Éric Gilbert les autres nouvelles de ce
journal et bien d'abord cette prise de
position à propos de l'avortement celle
du professeur l'horta Jacob le président
de l'ordre national des médecins en 74
avait combattu vigoureusement la loi vay
aujourd'hui sans renier ses idées sur le
plan philosophique il estime qu'on
pourrait revenir en arrière le
professeur s'explique au micro de
Jacques Lenoir
est inimaginable parce que je pense que
aucun député peu de député auront le
courage de supprimer la loi existante ça
ne veut pas dire que pour autant l'ordre
soit pour cette loi et leur maintient sa
position très stricte qui est hostile à
tout ce qui est compromet la vie dès la
conception c'est un ensemble d'éthique
que défendants pas de tanazie pas
d'expérimentation sur l'homme ça pas de
mort des foetus dès la conception
l'ordre n'a pas changé ce qui a changé
c'est les fêtes c'est lors d'un
constater c'est que dans la loi
précédente l'application n'a pas été
bonne or elle était moins nocive cette
application avait été correcte